[Music]
chuck you know these explainers they
just sort of come to me in these visions
during the day okay and then i tell our
producers we got to do an explainer on
that and they just jump on it so
psilocybin is actually responsible
for the explainers
who knew
i got my own cocktail of brain chemicals
doing doing its job right on so
i wanted to explore
uh atoms versus molecules
oh really
let me tell you something little adam
that's cool
tiny little particles that you are
yeah atoms versus molecules so just some
a little bit of pre-history here okay
the greeks imagined
that there was the smallest version of
any substance
that would then be indivisible of that
substance and so they used the word from
the greek which meant indivisible
which and that word happens to be adam
and that word has stuck with us
so
little did they know there are the
smallest versions of things
although they're the smallest version of
elements
the smallest version of an element is an
atom there's no such thing as a wood
atom in that sense right or a a
um
an air atom right you have to some often
you have to sort of break it down
further through the molecules and you
get to what the molecules are made if
you get to atoms then you break the
atoms down then you get to what the
atoms are made of
and right now we've got quarks
together they make the protons and
neutrons and we have electrons all right
in our experience of the universe so
there you have it but i want an
uncommitted part of the atom the
electrode
the electron oh yeah it can move around
yeah just go and hang out i'm gonna hang
out
until
i feel like being here i'm gonna get a
better offer over there
i think i got a better
let's call it an ionized atom that's
right the electron done left that's
right
the electron left
wait wait but you know what also you can
do with electrons they can only be given
up but they can be shared ah so you got
you two atoms that can share electrons
and the sharing of electrons is
precisely
what a molecule is that's what holds
them together okay but here's the point
i'm going to make and why i want to say
atoms versus molecules right okay
just hear this out you ready okay okay
the
atom the element hydrogen
at
in our life experience in the
temperatures and pressures we live in is
a gas hydrogen is a gas
okay
it is
it is flammable
okay
so if you have hydrogen there and you
light a match it rapidly combines with
oxygen and it explodes it basically
explodes right the hindenburg
filled with hydrogen that's a very light
gas much much lighter than air when that
caught fire i think it was in lakehurst
new jersey the whole thing went the
whole thing went that's aeronautical
move ever
i'm just saying like important yeah well
i mean come on let's how smart were
these people like let's take something
highly flammable
oh you were being
[Music]
i know it's i know it's a terrible
tragedy oh the humanity oh the humanity
but oh yes yes yes still not smart
move
the
live
well it worked until then right i mean
right so you get to say it after the
fact the point is hydrogen is flammable
okay oxygen is not itself flammable
but it makes other things burn
rapidly
okay that's why
when they when the oxygen mask drop in
the airplane you have to extinguish your
cigarette
okay which may be the reason why
in the first place
you have to extinguish your cigarette
okay so hydrogen is flammable oxygen
makes other things burn
you bring the two together
in a two to one ratio
you get h2o
a brand new substance that extinguishes
fires
nice
that's kind of cool actually that's kind
of cool yeah
so you cannot extrapolate
the behavior of a molecule
based on what you know the properties
are of its base atoms
oh it's completely different
i got another one for you ready okay
there's a metal one of the lightest
metals it's called sodium
sodium is a metal right i think it even
floats on water i think it is slightly
less dense it's like and it's very soft
you can cut it with a knife
okay
this is sodium
and
it is highly explosive i i shouldn't
have said it floats on water because you
don't want to do that experiment because
sodium in water reacts explosively wow
okay
explosively then there's this gas called
chlorine right which for a while was
considered as part of the the the the
chemical gas warfare in the second world
war if you inhale chlorine it's highly
caustic to your lungs
you can't breathe you suffocate and you
die damn okay
okay but with very clean lungs
very clean lungs though
because there's nothing there that's why
it's like a painful awful death but the
autopsy you're like this guy's chest is
clean as i don't know what
so
you
and by the way chlorine bleach i mean
this is you know part of what's going on
there but anyhow so if you combine equal
parts chlorine
and sodium
okay right you get
sodium chloride which is ordinary table
salt wow
you just went from noxious to delicious
no problem
so so there's so many examples of this
that it's just it's a chemist's
playground really
you you almost don't care what
properties it has as an atom let me play
in the molecule sandbox and see what i
can make out of it and what properties
it might then have by the way some atoms
have very clear and useful properties
like carbon
is available in many different forms
one of them is graphite which you use do
people still use pencils all right this
stuff in a pencil and
and we call that lead
but we shouldn't i remember when i was a
kid the paint on the outside the yellow
paint on the pencil had lead in it and
when they try to get rid of lead in the
environment that they get rid of the
lead in lead pencils and i said well
then how are you going to write you know
and but they're just referring to the
led
metal in the paint not the led form of
carbon in as graphite but anyway so the
other forms of carbon there's there's um
buck minster fullerene what hold on what
is buckminster fullerene i've never
heard you didn't know about that i've
never heard of it
nothing nothing about it that is that is
a carbon molecule that has 60 carbon
atoms
it's a carbon molecule with 60 carbon
atoms
and the 60 carbon atoms are the nodes
of the seams of a classic soccer ball
oh okay so they're
they fit together like right like a
molecular lego
like
and so and so so it makes a hollow ball
so that's the and it's it's like the old
geodesic domes it's named after
buckminster fuller and the geodesic
domes by the way
little known fact the very first
buckminster fuller dome was not made by
buckminster fuller
it was made by zeiss engineers in the
1920s when they invented a new optical
projector for a planetarium
and they said what are we going to test
this on we don't have any round ceilings
so they said what's the cheapest way we
can just make a round ceiling and so
these are good german engineers from the
1920s they got their sticks together
they stuck them together and they
created a geodesic dome the very first
one ever was made by zeiss in like 1923
something like that so and but later on
but it got forgotten because they just
did it to produce a different product
right the planetarium projector the
zeiss mark one and so
but anyhow so that's neither here nor
there actually it is there still
fascinating
exactly it is there it's just not here
so
um so that's another one and another one
is uh graphene graphene is like single
layer
thin
uh sheet of carbon atoms
and it's it has very interesting
properties
so so
atoms can be interesting unto themselves
that's all i'm trying to say but when
you start combining them with other
atoms
oh my gosh
to just get ready for the sideshow for
the circus uh what what of what that can
deliver for you now i can give you some
more sort of fun examples
um
do you remember
the periodic table of elements they're
columns
all right
so
so
the columns are not accidental
all right
all the atoms in a column
have the same configuration of electrons
in their outer shell
which means each one
can make exactly the same molecule as
the other
with other atoms
oh wow that's really cool okay
so now now have you ever wonder
why
uh
why science fiction writers are always
talking about silicon-based life you
ever hear that yeah yes of course
silicon yeah yep it's that star trek
episode instead of carbon right silicon
this famous star trek episode with the
hoarder which was the hoarder was this
life form
it looked kind of like a turtle but with
no head or legs and it kind of waddled
and it was basically made of rock and
once they analyzed it they found out yes
it is just made of rock okay and and
silicon isn't one of the active
ingredients in rocks silicon is one of
the most common ingredients in earth's
crust so most rocks are have significant
silicon in them there's a silicon-based
life and this was their attempt to
explore that so why would you do that
why not chlorine-based life i'll tell
you why because silicon is directly
below carbon on the periodic table in
fact you can make more molecules using
the carbon atom then all other molecules
combined on the periodic table so it's
not an accident that we're carbon based
and carbon is like the
hydrogen
third most chemically active ingredient
in the universe in the universe in the
universe so you went around saying oh
where
life on earth and we're special well
what are you made of hydrogen and oxygen
and carbon do these are the three most
common ingredients act chemically active
ingredients in the universe
so
silicon-based life would look down on us
they would say yeah we're a little more
special than yeah well carbon there's
about five times as much carbon in the
universe as silicon so you don't need to
appeal to silicon for this plus silicon
bonds are different right at
at goldilocks temperatures silicon bonds
are very strong
and they're hard to break which means
you can't do any experiments with it
whereas carbon you can make a bond it
can hang on oh let's break that and then
it tries to find other bonds and you can
you it it's largely responsible for the
for the
biodiversity uh on earth just simply
because carbon copies is highly firm
goes with anybody so in principle
wherever you had a carbon atom in life
you should be able to swap it with a
silicon atom so you have a carbon
dioxide there's silicon dioxide carbon
monoxide silicon monoxide all of those
match up because the elements is
directly exactly directly below carbon
all right so now
since we've gone through all this
here's the question
which one is cooler
who wins and the atoms versus molecules
face off
oh
yeah so i i have to thank you i'd ha i'd
have to say molecules
because you know we have 118 atoms
we have a bazillion molecules and in
fact the life as we know it would not be
possible without them
so let me just make that clear and
another point that's been buzzing around
the internet i'm going to make sure to
say it here by the way 90
of all atoms in the universe
are hydrogen and helium
holy crap everything else that makes
everything the rest about our lives
is in the small two percent of the
periodic table of elements
okay so in other words hydrogen and
helium are at the top all the rest are
two percent and less of the universe
okay so here's the point
that means the universe
is binary
okay
think about that
right
all right so if you wanted to say
uh being binary is the joint and that's
how everybody should be
i well you wouldn't have a universe
without that other two percent right
that gives meaning and shape to every
everything that is to basically to
everything right so just because some
group is not in the majority
is not reason to think that they're not
relevant
and the most extreme example of that are
the elements on the periodic table look
at that the universe is there anything
it cannot teach us
so
yeah atoms by definition all the other
atoms are on the atom spectrum
right
okay well that is super cool
okay yeah so i think molecules win this
one but i just wanted to highlight that
because in case people hadn't heard any
of those bits and pieces before well i
gotta tell you that is almost as cool as
buckminster fullerene
oh yeah which is gonna be the name of my
new band
that's a band name if i ever heard one
welcome to the stage ladies and
gentlemen chicago it's buck mr
fullerene so chuck i think you need
multiple lives so that you can live out
these these spontaneous fantasies that
you grace us with on star talk yeah man
that's it i'm doing it right now
it's the chuck multiverse the multiverse
that's my multiverse all right chuck we
gotta we gotta call it quits here uh
always good to have you there man always
a pleasure
all right this has been star talk
explainer videos adams versus molecules
neil degrasse tyson here keep looking up
[Music]
you